the professional mindset works in two
ways
it's important for us to grasp the
distinction
first the pro mindset is a discipline
that we use to overcome resistance
to defeat the self-sabotaging habits of
procrastination
self-doubt susceptibility to distraction
perfectionism and shallowness we enlist
the self-strengthening habits of
order regularity discipline
and a constant striving after excellence
that's not hard to understand
but what about the magic what about
madness
what about flashes of brilliance and
uncontrollable outbursts of genius
how does the professional mindset help
there
isn't it too severe too hardcore too
regimented
answer no the monk glimpses the face of
god
not by scaling a peak in the himalayas
but by sitting still
in silence yoga meditation and the
martial arts
access the soul by way of the body the
physical
leads to the spiritual the humble
produces the sublime
it seems counterintuitive but it's true
in order
to achieve quote-unquote flow magic
the zone we start by being common and
ordinary and workmanlike
we set our palms against the stones in
the garden wall
and search search search until it lasts
in the instant when we're ready to give
up our fingers fasten upon the secret
door
like a child entering a meadow we step
over the threshold
forgetting everything except the
butterfly that flits across our vision
from this play arises guernica
and the godfather and the guggenheim
museum bilbao
there's a well-known gunnery sergeant
who when his young marines complain
about their pay
explains that they get two salaries a
financial salary
and a psychological salary the financial
salary is indeed meager
but what about the psychological salary
the feeling of pride and honor
the sense of belonging to a brotherhood
with a brave and noble history
and knowing that no matter what happens
you remain a member of that fraternity
as long as you live how much the gunny
asks is that worth
you and i as artists and entrepreneurs
receive two salaries as well
the first might be called conventional
rewards money
applause attention that kind is fine if
we can get it
the problem for most of us is we can't
we bust our butts training and
practicing and studying and rehearsing
and nobody shows up nobody notices
nobody even knows we exist
no wonder people quit the struggle
requires too much agony for too little
payoff
that's the conventional reward then
there's a psychological reward
remember krishna told arjuna that he had
the right to his labor
but not to the fruits of his labor what
he meant was
conventional fruits does the monk
meditate
only to achieve enlightenment what if
that never happens
what does the dancer take from ballet
class
is it fun for the actor to perform why
does the singer sing or the filmmaker
shoot
when we do the work for itself alone and
i know how easy that is to say and how
hard it is to do
we're like that marine who sleeps in a
foxhole in the freezing rain
but who knows a secret that only he and
his brothers and sisters share
when we do the work for itself alone our
pursuit of a career
or living or fame or wealth or notoriety
turns into something else something
loftier and nobler
which we may never even have thought
about or aspired to at the beginning
it turns into a practice